The Mandelbrot Set
has many intriguing features.
But its biggest mysteries
lie in its complex fractal boundary.
Zooming in to different boundary regions
reveals some astounding features...
a valley of seahorses,
parades of elephants
and miniature versions of the set itself.
So we can sort of keep finding
nests, a sequence of smaller and smaller
Mandelbrot sets,
all one inside of the next.
Here at the boundary,
mathematicians are probing for answers.
As you look at it
it sort of seems like one blob,
but if you really ask like,
is it all connected?
Or maybe if I zoom in far enough,
there's some separating piece.
This question is central
to a 40 year old problem
called the Mandelbrot
Locally Connected Conjecture,
or MLC.
If the set is locally connected,
that means that no matter what point
you choose to examine
or how far you zoom in,
the area will always look like
one nice connected section.